[Music]
sleeping in tidy
extremely whities not having a screen on
your window do you want all the bugs
because that's how you get all the bugs
bringing home a box of four donuts for a
family of five i realize this is going
to be a broad comedy poking fun at the
far right but
18 seconds in and this is feeling all of
the broad and much less of the comedy
also not including any pictures on the
front page above the fold do you think
we read the langley falls post for the
articles
steve you've only got one sister be nice
thinking kindness is directly related to
scarcity
steve's big boy hair isn't gonna come in
any faster with you taunting him
public pubic patter do you know lou
ferrigno was deaf
i don't know somehow it's hard to take
him as seriously better than being tone
deaf
like this humor is and even was in 2005
also incredible hulk shaming you won't
like him when he's shamed
francine you be very careful out there
today we're at terror alert orange
not labeling your fridge chart as far as
i know you just like vertical color
rainbows that allow you to indicate your
favorite color of the day
damn it stan lives are at stake
good thing he packed his gun with the
toaster only bullets otherwise he might
have damaged the counter or cupboards
hey steve how's it going with that gal
on the lacrosse team i picked out for
you yeah yeah the point of the humor is
that stan is supposed to be a terrible
father and chauvinistic pig and blah
blah blah so how about
five self-aware sins then we'll just
move on with our day
actually dad i have decided to go for
the brass ring comparing a woman's merit
to a copper and zinc alloy aside if
steve's going this route why not say
gold
or diamond or simply the out of my
league ring also choosing to eat eggs
and bacon when there's a box of donuts
nearby
i think you got a shot steve as long as
you don't wear that shazam shirt
that's zachary leavist all right i've
had it with these donuts which have gone
from four in the opening to five and now
eight
i really don't want to be the donut
police this entire episode so here's the
sinner's dozen to cover the rest of the
scene
i wonder what the donut police's
favorite snack is you know we can't all
look like those anorexic aliens in the
james cameron movies
movies plural i guess i'll give you
aliens cause the xenomorphs are indeed
skin and bones but are you suggesting
that the nti should
also be included in this conversation
because those things were probably here
long before us
and can be all sorts of curvy if they
want oh god i've got a bear claw in my
ass
if you've got a bear claw on your butt
then you put it there because none of
these donuts made it there
unless your butt is what we think use
your stomach now how about a beer
i'll just pass over any problematic
humor sins here to point out that unless
she can fly there is
no way her dick van dyking that ottoman
would have resulted in this trajectory
uh hey george it's uh it's god this
phone call bit goes on beating off
around the bush for quite some time
dad get off me i have to study for my
term paper
this is the only issue hayley has with
this
your scenario half dead considering he's
dragging him and you can't even see the
eyes why wouldn't you assume the dog is
all the way dead
unless you're in a relationship with
danny trejo you should never sleep this
close to a machete
i was an olympic skier before the cia
switched my brain without goldfish well
what were we supposed to do just let
east germany win that gold medal
not on my watch so wait you cared so
much about skiing that you switched out
the brain of an east german competitor
with a goldfish but you still let them
win gold medals and tons of other events
and this is 1986 not an olympic year
meaning this is some
lower profile ski championship that stan
thought was so important
this is the weirdest backstory for a
character ever written so even if those
glass shards managed to get through the
ski mask he was wearing when he jumped
out of the mall how did he get the ski
mask
off without dislodging them picnic in
the park i can't
i have this paper dude i was going to
sit turning down a date to study but
then i realized he said picnic which i
would turn down even if the only other
option were a razer blade colonoscopy so
the sin
as always is picnics
sorry about that once every seven hours
like clockwork this is either said for
you not paying attention to your cycle
or purposely timing your gooseblurd for
this encounter
hillary is here of her own free will
because she wants to have dinner with
steve
kidnapping hillary look out for the
mines
murder if steve needs power i'll rig the
school election and make him student
body president thinking being student
body president will give one anything
more than further reason for classmates
to hate them
and wedgies so so many wedgies
also this show does the opposite of
family guy most of the time and then it
has a much clearer focus and falls more
in line with a standard sitcom style
scenario and the humor can be above
average a lot of the time but then it
has to occasionally go to these pop
culture one-off jokes that make family
guy
so [ __ ] irritating to watch doris
could you please send in our high school
mascot not only is the mascot already
there but in full mascot gear it must be
nice to be a seth macfarlane cartoon and
not have to worry about things like
physics or reality or your audience's
standards i want to ride the buffalo
writing the buffalo and no not the fun
sexual position where girls on top and
you grab her brass before screaming a
different girl's name and i mean i mean
i've heard that's a thing and now that i
think about it that might be called the
bucking brock i mean
that's what i heard once when i was
being distracted while trying to read
the bible and donate money to cancer
research
roger said that his body squirted that
green goo every seven hours so it's
absolutely shocking to see that his
chair is still clean the next morning
after nearly 10 hours have gone by i
never knew todd's mom had a website
pretty sexy huh guys sure is todd in
case anyone's keeping track the episode
is averaging an incest joke every seven
minutes or so
and when i say joke i mean a character
mentions casual incest and that is
apparently supposed to equal funny
it's too risky right now i'll come back
tonight in case anyone's keeping track
the episode is averaging a bestiality
joke every five minutes or so and when i
say
joke i mean a character mentions best mr
smith i'm afraid there's a problem with
your son oh god he's gay this is it this
is the gay call
i know i said the thing earlier about
this being the point of stan's character
but that's just
hell also popping that many pills or any
pills without water
that was crazy to think any girl could
ever like me
there is truth to this statement but it
has less to do with looks and more to do
with being a terrible person
but if you expect to get any boob i'm
gonna need a buttload of twinkies
racketeering
a grown man getting a wedgie at least it
was an atomic
it's okay this one will be mine i wanted
to like me i
i i like this better anyway that's gonna
leave a mark
you're cool with chicks you're cool with
chicks i think i can i think i can
wait a minute that's it i just need to
get a dog
and women will be all over my jock that
doesn't make sense
that's a messed up looking dog
that was lovely score score score yes
yes yes steve this is your father
get out of here dad i'm not coming out
please honey this is what i do
don't be mad at him i'll gouge your left
eye out with my thumb
i'm not your freak